create a culture of this being a common
thing you visit you can have a check-in
every Sunday so Sunday you know at
dinner youall are going to have your
here's what I'm loving and here's how I
want to play even more and that's your
time to share that's your feedback time
commit to the theater so if you're
wanting to play with some specific
archetype or have a Kind of Night commit
to the theater like set up the room turn
your phone on do not disturb make a very
Sacred Space bless the room set a prayer
go deep there are so many ways that
couples are just habitually making love
or habitually having sex without
actually dropping the veil and seeing
like do we need to enact something that
needs to be brought into the light so
that we can make love soul to soul is
there something that needs to be said or
something that needs to be expressed or
something that needs to be done